welcome welcome welcome to chest coms
top 5 countdown of the best games from
the year 2019 it's gone it's over it's
in the books say goodbye but not before
you watch this video and give us a
subscribe down low let's check out
things as they were in 2019 as far as
how the chest comm staff voted them we
start right here with this battle
between McCandlish melee and roughneck
Oren
where it seems that the move that has
been played many times and the only move
that ever been played in this position
Queen takes d5 should be played you're
down upon the knight is pinned let's
just regain that material Roth nakorn
instead decided to bring the wrath and
play Knight takes d5 a double exclam
move and don't ask me to apologize
because when you give up a queen before
move 10 and do so to have long-term
compensation like this it's absolutely
bananas he now played the move Knight
takes it to check which of course is
perfect to keep the White King in the
center and off balance
you can't take because now you're giving
me back my material with interest that
meant that white had to keep the King in
the center and after Queen to e3 we have
the one moment where I'm gonna ask you
to pause the video and try to play the
brilliant move that Roth mcaren did here
it's another double X claim in my book
and it is Bishop to e6 we don't want to
take back material in games where we've
already sacrificed too much to get back
anyway
and what I mean by that is that when
your opponent has a major piece and
let's say you have a bunch of small
pieces if that major piece can start
exerting pressure your minors will often
never get coordinated or get active a
line that shows that is right here
Queen g5 check and we take the pawn
followed by rapid development and in a
few moves it's actually white who has
the more dominant coordinated looking
minor pieces where black is struggling
for activity so what's fascinating about
this game is that Roth the Corrin only
has one piece for the Queen right now
that's not a lot but he still does the
right principle thing to make sure he
emphasizes activity with the move Bishop
e6 and points out that if you just try
to keep your material and take pawns
I have rook c8 bringing one more piece
to the file and then king of seven bring
the next piece to the file and if you
really want to see the full analysis of
it you can check out the video I did at
chest comm for premium members and my
blog where I break down all the fancy
ways black and checkmate in the game
white didn't play Bishop takes c7 and
instead played Bishop g5 but lost back
material desperately trying to guard the
d8 square and after he ran out of ways
to do it
black castles long and went on to win in
a brilliant attack where the miners
dominated the Queen and ultimately got
things going against the King on the
first rank that was number five let's
check out what took the four spot here
in our 2019 countdown taking the number
four spot from chef Tom's point of view
was this amazing game by international
master Casa Corley as black taking on
Grandmaster Alexandre muy senko now and
what was our had been up to this game a
traditional Queens gambit declined
structure with nothing too fancy going
on white does the right thing in this
position to justify the last move f3 by
playing the movie for this is the idea
in this Queen gave a structure when you
haven't gone for minority attack you're
trying to get a big Center and then tell
some tales about it the problem is that
Casa Corley came very well prepared he's
a friend of mine I know he knows how to
use the engine and in this position he
shocked his higher rated opponent by
sacrificing not just one night on e4 but
two nights and then winning the bishop
with it launching what was about to be a
brilliant attack now after rook f2 black
plays Bishop takes h3 let's bring more
pieces in but rook d1 was played because
it doesn't seem like black has the
knockout blow at least not now and
really put the pressure on Corley to
justify his to Knight sacrifice it's my
time to put some pressure on you as
we're gonna do at least once in every
one of these games and try to solve the
finishing touch here for black it's the
only way for black to justify this
attack and the reason why this game was
voted into our top 5 assuming you've
done so I'm gonna tell you that a lot of
you might have even suggested rook to e6
makes sense you're threatening rook g6
check the problem is after each takes d5
I guard that square with my bishop and
your rook lift while fancy is sort of
wasted there is another way to do a rook
lift
that maybe some of you found the move
rook to e5 are you kidding me
double X clam you you already down a
piece you sacrifice a rook for a pawn
not even because you're gonna use the G
file necessarily with the rook but
because you've opened up a new avenue
that exposes the F to Brooke and points
out that while white is up a ton of
material he doesn't have easy ways to
coordinate them to defend against
obvious checkmate threats coming Queen
takes f2 and Queen g2 follows in the
game white played 94 we're gonna show
why that doesn't work in a second rook
f1 was the only other try I'm not gonna
say it saved the game at all but it
would have gone to a less lost position
after the move Bishop takes f1 you have
91 that's the whole point you free the
square and White has to transition into
the endgame and when I say has to it's
not a problem black has a rook and three
pawns count them three pawns from the
minor pieces so Corley should have and
would have gone on to win that game if
that had happened the two Nets at night
sacrifice is justified but in the game
where Senko doesn't find that he plays
Knight d4 thinking that he has plenty of
time to defend with doubled rooks on the
second rank but after Queens g3 king h1
I lied I'm gonna give you two chances to
try to play like the brilliant Cossack
Orly and if you did so good on you
Bishop to g4 finishes things off there's
no way to stop Bishop to f3 check if you
take it I make you on g1 because of that
black played Bishop to f1 to try to meet
Bishop f3 check with Bishop g2 but that
doesn't solve anything after Queen h3
and Queen takes G to the finish is over
finish him might as well get some
sub-zero action will pop right and with
them with that number 4 is in the books
let's check out our third best game from
the Year 2019 the game number 3
between Avon Sarich and I dean Suleiman
Lee has us wondering how exactly an
endgame made it into the top five but
when you see the finish here for white
you're gonna you're gonna understand why
we really loved what we saw now in this
position you're facing a critical
decision white sacrifice the exchange
and got some pretty good compensation
for it played rather brilliantly in my
mind up to here but now the rooks are
finally getting the job done this tower
is blocking the HP pawn and this tower
is about to help the b-pawn become a
real boy or girl on b1 whatever whatever
his or her life choice is but if you
calculate fast here as white you might
find a way to justify the entire
exchange sac with further sacrifices and
show that sometimes the little people
can get things done around here even if
your opponent has two big towers of
power in this position Sarge plays
Bishop e2 ignoring the infiltration of
the second rank ignoring the threat of
coming to b2 which has a threat of rook
c1 and I'm gonna get a new queen because
the intention the entire time was to
just part ways with the last remaining
rook and have the pawns do the job
against the rooks and Bishop and King
and I meant to say all of those pieces
the rooks and Bishop and King it
flipping bananas right in this position
the pawns get out of control they are
Unchained and they start to run up the
board right after Bishop g8 keep that
rook out of play
improve the knight temporarily but not
even because we're really trying to
guard c3 it's because we're gonna try to
start using our pesky and here come the
boys the D pawn joins the fight the e
pawn is not too far to follow Knight
takes e4 pointing out you can't take as
you give me a queen so that takes
advantage of the bishops sort of
impotent and guards the d6 pawn at the
same time black gets himself off the
discovered check but it's too little too
late
once the other pawns get going they are
too fast running up the board now in
this moment as much as we love this game
and we did vote it in purely because of
the beautifulness of the pawns I'm not
going to lie full disclosure black had
one opportunity that I analyzed with the
engine right here right now
a four straw that he missed really hard
to blame mr. suleiman lee because when
you face this kind of pond pressure a
lot of people crack in the game he
played the move rook takes d7 which was
kind of a defensive sacrifice he had
been pairing all preparing all along a
chance to give back all the pieces and
get a draw but there was only one right
way to get back all the pieces and fight
for equality you had to take with the
King on e7 giving up the bishop on e8
and then quickly bring the other rook to
g5 and give up even more material to
reach a position where the rook stands a
fighting chance to draw here against the
knight and two pawns
unfortunately suleiman lee did not find
this played the defensive sacrifice he
had been planning all along with rook
takes d7 and after takes bishop takes
the finishing touch was rather brilliant
for suresh because it had to do with the
proper foresight of why we study our
King and pawn endings Knight to b6 was
the move the Suleiman he missed a
surprising move because he thought he
could take e7 and then the King would
surely get back in time for me to
sacrifice my rook and get it drawn king
upon ending unfortunately the white King
understood that idea and shoulders him
just in time the shouldering method is a
very educational takeaway because often
in these positions players assume just
come straight forward right the problem
with coming straight forward and these
types of end games is that when when the
enemy King gets here you are actually
the one who's blocked from accessing the
next rank and if you advance your pawns
too far now your pawn is in front of
your king and indeed these end games can
be drawn these King and pawn endings can
be drawn if the sacrifice is made at the
right time so you don't want the pawn to
get in front of the King instead you
shoulder the King by bringing it to the
Kings side and entering to the fifth
rank and a square that is just out of
the reach of the black King and indeed
sulamani resigned let me show you the
finish of the King upon ending as it
would be the King goes to g7 rather than
taking the square with the pawn we play
King g5 and if the sacrifice on g8
happens we get King on the sixth pawn on
the fifth which is always what you want
it always wins the game because even if
it's white to move you have the timing
to slide over and March the pawn up
ultimately arriving at h7 and welcoming
your brand-new baby girl
Gabriella because it starts with the G
to the g8 square obviously if it was
black to move you always win King on the
sixth part of the fifth cuz you just
take the square they've given up but a
very very brilliant finish here from
Sarich timing it perfectly gets to h5
sulemani resigns and he earns our number
three spot for best game with this
awesome exchange sacrifice and run away
the pawns coming up let's take a look at
number two number two coming at us right
now from the young and rising Russian
star we might as well just call him a
superstar at this point daniil Dube of
he is the second of Magnus Carlsen he is
feared by many for his preparation with
computers like Leela and alpha zero and
nothing was more impressive by him on
the board himself than this win versus
Rasmus Payne and 2019 now the thing that
I love about this position is the
combination that starts here truly
exposes an engine oversight and again
how often do we get to say that anymore
as humans but the engines can think for
a very long time but they have a very
very difficult time seeing the mating
net that was in store for mr. Spain as
the combination gets underway but dubov
had already played a brilliant novelty
by counseling long bringing the Knight
to g5 and launching a King side attack
with no justification at least we didn't
think so as far as chess principles went
ultimately it doesn't matter
he gets a brilliant opportunity to
finish the game in style check out the
full video over at chess calm as well as
my blog for the other analysis I'm
mentioning but this moment right here
was why it took the number two spot and
here we go
Knight to d5 we remove the defender from
f6 to bring in the rook to h7 why you
ask just so we can give up more material
by taking on f7 currently white is down
a rook and a piece but all that will not
be for naught
after Queen takes g6 rook King to f8 we
have Queen age six rook g7 and Bishop
takes d5 now this position is amazing
the threat of Queen h8 followed by rook
g8 and Queen takes maid puts black in an
almost impossible to solve spot in fact
there was no clear solution in the game
he played king e8
which you can hardly blame them because
even the engines have a hard time seeing
why that's a problem but the best move
here was the move Bishop to f5 the only
way for Spain to stay in the game it
allows e4 and actually allows the attack
to continue with a further sacrifice
really hard to justify going for this
because again just about anything here
still Falls to mate things like Queen e7
we have ideas of f6 and Bishop c6 things
like moving the rook still run in two
different types of mating nets here
there's no clear way that black even
gets out of it but at least there was a
chance to survive in some critical
variations again that I went over in the
full video of Ron chess calm but the
main thing here is that black can hardly
be blamed for not going for Bishop f5
check because when he plays the move
King e8 it seems like there's a path to
a draw how is white gonna deliver the
goods after Queen h5 kingdon
indeed dubov kind of feigns like he
agrees he plays a little bit of tickle
brings the king to d7 and maybe he's
moments away from considering a draw
just kidding that I was lying about that
not so fast he wasn't moments away from
considering a draw he was moments away
from proving Spain wrong by playing the
move Bishop to e6 check and saying
actually there is more than a perpetual
here because after King to c6 we have
Queen to f3 check we bring the Queen
back into the game and this is your
moment to pause the video and find the
final combination the dooba played that
is literally a forced mate and 10
according to the engine see if you can
do it come on I believe in you pause the
video force main 10 don't go look up the
game don't do that don't just come on
pause the video and see if you can solve
yourself some puzzle rush style forced
mate in 10 the move is the combination
begins with Bishop takes e4 sacrifice
more material because you don't need it
anyway at this point checkmate is all
that matters the whole idea is not only
do you force the King further into your
territory but you start removing key
defenders of the c-file
helping the only pieces that weren't in
the game get involved that's exactly why
things like King takes c4 don't work
because white comes in too quickly to
the C file in the game black played King
a5 and after Queen d5 check blocks with
the bishop but the mate continues with
b4 King a4 if you want to pause
the video one less time you have like
two seconds to do it the finishing touch
was Queen did she too threatening
Queen to c2 and Queen to b3 mate Bishop
takes b4 is played so that Queen to c2
can allow King a5 but that one move
opens up the C file for a temporary
moment and dubov takes advantage of it
by coming back to c6 and playing the
move Bishop to b3 which threatens not
just Queen a4 mate but also an even
fancier mate and three that you can
solve after Bishop d7 if you're fast or
I'm going to show you
Queen to c1 King takes Queen c2 and
Queen a2 this combination that started
if I know you're like hey that was a lot
to take in let's back up you're welcome
I'm gonna do that it really started all
the way back with 90 d5 and it was a
position that again super brilliant not
only because it came from the attack
that it did but because the engines
couldn't even really see just how White
was gonna be able to deliver the
finishing touches but to see it in real
action by this this brilliant guy who
will be a household name for many years
to come
definitely one of my faves it was
actually the game I personally voted
number one full confession time here but
that's not because our next game is not
just as brilliant and gonna leave you
breathless with that let's dive into our
top game of 2019 here we go baby it's
number one and you see a name ali reza
firoozeh right you see his face now in
front of you normally he's on the
brilliancy side of these brilliant sea
things unfortunately for him karthik ian
had other things in mind in this game
that was already instructive as far as
the improvements being made to the
king's indian i'm gonna dive into the
critical moment and show you firoozeh
facing kind of a weird queen a5 does the
principle thing says the queen's a
target out there and let's go kick her
out of my house right go home little
lady and she says I have other plans
Queen takes c3 double X clam sacrificing
a queen before move 10 again not
something you see every day except I
guess twice in this top 5 video series
countdown to take III but unlike any of
the other sacrifices to this game I
literally spent hours analyzing this and
have no real ways that that white could
have improved upon it the one moment is
right here right now if all here as a
real lie
he needs to quickly try to give back as
much material as possible and hopes to
safeguard the king the problem is that
even that doesn't necessarily help
because even if he found the move rook
g1 to give up the pawn with check black
doesn't have to take back the material
and ultimately allow white to do things
like win the e3 pawn and sit with a
safety 93 black can actually just keep
the pieces on the board and continue to
dominate on the dark squares and what
you're gonna find if you let the engines
think here is that they tend to agree
black has plenty of compensation and how
often do we get to say that we talk
about practical elements when we
sacrifice Queens early we talk about how
shocking and amazing and beautiful it
was okay even though it really wasn't
objectively the right decision not the
case with this combination and why it
took our number one just an absolutely
brilliant move that forces us to
remember the truths of chess which is
that squares the initiative threats King
safety are the things that really matter
in chess not just material right
material should be seen as the tools we
use to expose and build on those
weaknesses but it's a means to an end
and that's exactly what happens here on
the dark squares for firoozeh
meaning he finds his end he played Queen
to c1 instead of giving the pawn back
that was the only chance to even keep it
murky and black never looks back
Bishop h6 were already threatening
things like Knight g3 and things with E
- so g4 played to give a little freedom
but after Knight f4 you can't take III
because of Knight G to check winning
back material and up the Peace King b1
we have 96 Black was threatening to
check winning the Queen again King c2
another piece joins the fight we keep
the Bishop on this diagonal not can
allow g5 to close it out and and again
the crazy thing about this game is these
are not the kind of moves you normally
see all the rezident future play
defensive passive moves normally he's
the guy on the attack black makes a
threat on a4 brings another piece into
the game just dominating despite being
down a queen relocates the bishop to the
dark square diagonal of what she started
there and for the fianchetto and after a
few more moves finishes things off in
style especially with this very nice
move rook c5 that keeps all kinds of
threats alive doubling rooks the
now come to c6 without blocking them
work on c8 f5 is an idea
the pieces are dominating the Queen she
has no targets and in this last critical
moment right here lets you pause the
video and find the way the cart ikan
finishes the game here against alia reza
firoozeh sometimes you do everything you
can with the pieces against the Queen
and then you cash in your chips and go
to a winning endgame and if you took the
time to solve it then you definitely
found Bishop takes c3 very nice you get
the discovery on the Queen and take away
the last real critical defender of the
King on c2 in the game all the reza
tries to bail out by sacrificing the
Queen back for a bunch of material it
doesn't work
the only other tribe wasn't moved let's
say we moved the Queen to anywhere with
safety a fun line I gave just to show
how the pieces come to life now that the
C pawn is gone starts with Bishop to e5
we trade and then the pieces start
coming after the King and my favorite
finish of any did any of the games we
did in this video is right here
nice c4 check rook b2 forced mate and
three and with it you get to tell mom
and dad that you check mated a King on
d5 with a knight and they'll be like how
is that even possible you can't do that
you can't checkmate a king with it only
a knight on d5 there's so many center
squares I don't know why mom and dad
talk like this with you right that
sounds more like my teenager okay anyway
Bishop takes c3 brilliant stuff I hope
you found it and after Queen takes c5
they headed to an endgame where yes with
a little bit of technique required black
converts it unfortunately the end of our
2019 best games countdown doesn't get to
come to a close with with checkmates but
still a nice conversion capped off with
this great move here h6 which is a well
calculated combination preventing the
rook from dominating the seventh rank
because after taking h4 White has to
prevent the two pawns and if you come
back to the seventh rank black gets here
just in time and wins the game so
because of that instead we had the
variation we did where ultimately the
pawns became just one too many for
mister firoozeh and he resigns
borderline as zoogs one here at the end
of the game so with that we bring our
top 5 games of 2019 video to a close as
i've mentioned a few times you can check
doubtful reviews of each of these games
where I dive into the opening more
educational takeaways and some heavy
lifting analysis over at chess comm both
in my blog as well as the premium videos
for all Diamond members so thanks for
tuning in give us a like give us a share
if you like our best of 2019 countdown
and we'll see you around on chess calm
[Applause]
[Music]